The happiest guy in the world
right now is Jimmy Carter
because now he's out
of the history books for being
the worst president ever I would
give him a poor grade
because of the way we left
Afghanistan.
And I think that that was
terrible I guess I'll leave it
at that.
I would give him a very poor
grade because of that night
great tactics there I guess you
would say a 7 and 1/2 out of 10
try not to be mean here
but because again he was not
given a great situation to begin
with but he hasn't done anything
to improve said situation
and Yeah three or four Max give
them a five I don't know.
I don't see much going
on I'm much change honestly know
a through F what's a middle
letter in the alphabet you
probably don't want me to answer
that question see that's what
I'd give them a C stinks I just
don't think he's doing much
of anything but Messing up
the country I don't know where
to start there's inflation
the border forget about a pound
of bacon now Yeah I love bacon
who doesn't like bacon
and it's $9 a pound.
Now forget about this guy's got
to go.